all right guys how's it going today is
well depending upon when you're watching
this uh it's thursday
jenna's birthday is this weekend and i
never know what to get her because she's
kind of a difficult person
and all aspects of the word difficult
if you're wondering what's going on i
was
trying to lock my car put my backpack on
hold my coffee and juggle my phone at
the same time so the gift that i'm
ending up giving her is do you guys
remember when we went to the rug store
and i bought that purple rub we've had a
very successful day today
for rugs yeah you stole the rug i wanted
it was too big for you no it wasn't
okay i asked you and you said you were
not ready i would not have done that to
you do you guys see how she treats me i
pick up the perfect rug and she's not
just kidding it's okay they're going to
be so mean to me in the comments there's
gonna be a hashtag it's gonna be like
save jenna's carpet or jenna's wrong
hashtag
well it turns out the rug didn't exactly
work for my room but it's gonna work for
jenna's room
so
i guess i have to use my body
so i'm going to wrap the rug up and give
it to her as birthday gift it's kind of
a boring gift considering the fact that
she was there when we bought it and it
was supposed to be for me but now it's
for her but now she won't have to buy a
carpet so i think it's all gonna work
out i wanted to surprise her by wrapping
it though so she'll have something to
unwrap for her birthday i also have a
little surprise that i'm working on but
i'm not sure if it's gonna all work out
in time for her actual birthday
but if it doesn't
just have to have the surprise be
another day so let's go buy some
wrapping paper
oh god it's bright
guys i can't believe what i just did as
i was walking down the steps and i
walked out of the steps i put my camera
away every time i put my backpack on my
apple watch gets stuck on my backpack so
i was taking it off and it just
face down and the sound that it made was
just
earth shattering
this is my first apple watch that i've
broken
i'm so sad it's like it's super
super broken
happy birthday
this is perfect i think
she loves pretzels
happy birthday happy birthday happy
birthday she likes pretzels a lot but
i'm not sure if that's
what we should do maybe i'll get maybe
oh god i'm so indecisive we've got the
wrapping paper should i get her a bow or
a ribbon or something maybe
there's a very specific wine that she
likes it's uh the 11.99 prosecco which
you usually can get at ralph's but i
don't think they have it here it's only
11.99 if you buy five bottles but if you
buy
one it's fifteen dollars
i need to get out of here i have to
shoot in an hour and a half and i'm not
ready so upset about my watch yeah oh
god oh geez oh my goodness
just put that back these are hitting
everything
why do these things happen to me is it
because i'm careless
i'm not careless i care a lot because
now that we're back here we can assess
the damage
looks
pretty damaged to me
i'm sorry my friend
i have had lindsey sterling's album on
repeat for like the past
since it's been out it's so incredible
you guys have to seriously go check it
out if you don't we're not friends
anymore i'm about to head to a shoot
i had to order amazon prime
amazon prime now delivers things within
an hour it's absolutely incredible
i have a sock problem i don't know where
my socks go i actually have absolutely
no idea and i told myself that from now
on i'm only allowed to get socks that
are the same exact brand same color same
everything because it's a serious
problem and here what did i do i was in
desperation mode i have no socks i have
to head to a shoot i ended up getting
these socks which
power your
gosh maybe if i just keep getting all of
no that's not going to work oh you look
good
i just want to look good
i miss maddie jenna's had him for a day
because this shoot today is supposed to
go really late and i don't know
if i'll be back in time time
oh goodness gracious going pack you guys
up
um hi so i
living in los angeles the traffic is
almost always terrible especially if
you're trying to get from the west side
to the east side or on the east side to
the west side basically going anywhere
traffic is just absolutely terrible it's
never it's never good even in the middle
of the night if you're trying to get
somewhere it's usually
pretty awful
there was another story that i was gonna
tell you guys when i hit record but then
i started listening to music and i
forgot
so
if i think of
whatever it was that i was gonna tell
you
i don't know it feels weird though
driving and there's no maddie in the
back seats
he's like my little buddy
i miss him so much
oh my goodness
all right well i guess we'll listen to
music again
yeah i've got a question for you so i
posted this video about going to this
restaurant called portillos and everyone
tells me that i was pronouncing it wrong
tell me hey everybody it's me greg
miller i'm from chicago and i will tell
you right now it's called fortillos why
is it called fortillos because of this
man this is dick portillo in 1963 he
founded the dog house it was a one
little shop he did out in villa park and
now it's a chain but in a change we're
gonna say but it's like you're a local
business that has a million things like
43 restaurants now i assure you it's
called fortillos i understand the
tortilla thing i moved from chicago to
missouri to california and i brought my
wiener dog
portillo okay good i'm glad you i was
like you brought what my wiener dog
named portillo that i named after
portillo's out here and when i got out
here all the time people
you go drop them off at petcamp and
they'll bring them over like we love
tortillo and i'm like that's not his
name and if you say it again i'll slap
the taste out of your mouth because i'm
sorry i'm
i'm very
in
love with portillos portillo's is my
home
is it bad if i got a cheeseburger there
yes
stop there is the video if you go to
youtube and you search greg miller's
recommended cortillo's order it's right
there it's very simple on what to get a
cheeseburger is not there justine that
was a bad move to do why would you go to
portillo's hot dogs and get a cheese no
don't know the cheeseburgers are great
cheeseburgers are great the salads are
great the tamales are great that's not
where you start and then my friend got a
chicken club sandwich
and my sister got chocolate cake because
she's a vegetarian no the chocolate
cake's fine the chocolate cake's fine
yeah that's a good move no the chocolate
cake did you get the chocolate cake
shake
no we just got like we actually got two
pieces of chocolate cake you should have
gotten the chocolate cake shake if you
watch my video on youtube over it kind
of funny do you think his full does he
does dick have a middle name or is that
is that it i'm sure he does but he
hasn't shared it with me i'm not gonna
go like into his privacy setting and
figure it out it's really cute every
restaurant every particulars you go to
right outside there's a dick love sharon
and then it's in a heart because that's
his wife's name oh that's the sweetest
thing ever this is really great i'm just
glad that we really cleared this up
because it was a real issue for the past
like two weeks yeah so i'm sorry youtube
people who haven't had the the ability
to go to portals here's the good news
though is that you should go to patellas
obviously there's a million in chicago
there's one in indiana there's one now
wisconsin uh but if you're if you don't
have a portillo's in your neck of the
woods you can have it shipped anywhere
in the continental united states really
yeah like frozen yeah yeah it gets there
the italian beef spot on fratella's hot
dogs not as good but if you've never had
it before you might as well do it the
first they
what did you notice about everybody
working there when you went there in the
assembly line the hot dog what did you
notice what did you notice about the
staff
uh i don't know they're all wearing
paper portillo's hats
when they ship it to you when they ship
it to you there's instructions on how to
make the food the first instruction is
put on the supplied hat and you put on
the little portillo's hat and you just
you feel like you're living your dream
hey so greg how how long have you been
uh working for potillos i have not now
here's the thing i thought this was
gonna be like a simple explanation we're
now running into that one here well i
mean here's where we go you want to get
nuts now everybody's nuts everybody
who's from chicago knows porcellos they
know there's the only honor
that you can get to confirm that you are
a celebrity in chicago is to sign a
photo and have it put up at portillo's
which they then put up at all the
portillos
signed one last week
i signed one last year
greg miller
congratulations thank you it's you know
it's been a it's been a long road of 33
years of eating italian beef yeah and
hot dogs but i i did it i mean you
brought your wiener all the way to i
brought my wiener all the way to san
francisco and started putting into
people's faces
and i was like
okay so i am super excited because you
know i'm a little obsessed with pokemon
go um but i just saw your a pokedex and
then
it's pretty it's very nice
so okay what's your channel alright so
my channel is absolutely tech so like
absolutely anyways yes um so yeah i do
pokemon go vlogs every once in a while
i'm in the process of moving so i know
and you said that you go to the pier all
the time like if i would have known this
before like we were always at the pier
we gotta try and make it happen before
we go we do i'm down yeah let's do it
this would be great so i'm gonna show
you the depth okay okay the dex is full
i have literally one more pokemon i need
to get and that's actually muck
which sits right there
83 i believe is far-fetched um one of
these is kangaskhan the other one's mr
mime and then one of them is ditto which
really isn't in the game yeah yet
so let's see your highest okay girl i
got you i got you i cried i was like i
don't want to show you mine like it's
kind of embarrassing but
all right so check this out so um no i
this is not like a spoof app this is the
real app so some of these actually
caught so like some of the dragonites i
caught all these eye evolved arcanines
all over the place um i actually have an
eevee spawn at my house so i get a ton
of eevees
a couple blastoise on here
um but yeah this is this is my decks
this is what i got so far super dope
look at this now you're just showing off
so
really good look at this is insane but
my grind is dumb though it's like this
is i love
i love the game stuff so i do it's it's
been so much fun but it's more fun when
you kind of go with like other people
and hang out
everyone's so sick of me talking about
it so i kind of like
stop for a little bit it's so fun like
it's like the best social game yeah that
you could play like you got to go with
friends like it's it's dope and i mean
it's completely ridiculous and it makes
you not an adult but whatever that's
okay it's mostly like adults that i see
out playing it so that's like the
funniest thing because you know the kids
are in school so like mommy and daddy
are out playing pokemon and that's the
funniest part like i remember one of my
friends like dude all these kids i'm
like yeah but the kids aren't school now
so it's just running around looking at
the phones running
sounds good
so we're we're on shoot here for
something i don't even know i i
yeah i don't think we're talking about
it yeah it's like you look like a she
looks like a biker boy so it's all yo
what's up okay i gotta go do whatever i
have to do and i'll see you guys in a
second so we just got done filming
something that you will probably see in
about a month so
look at that but i tell you hey this is
the thing that we filmed a month ago
uh that's all for today i'll see you
guys tomorrow
probably see you tomorrow
yeah bye
oh god oh god
we can work with this